donc vous répondez non à 76% on va
rester à l'étranger
la grande bretagne elle a bien d'autres
soucis que hong kong
ça ne l'est plus depuis 1997 en tous les
cas officiellement et on le comprend
réellement ce soir vu la situation à
londres alors la question c'est de
savoir si boris johnson va convoquer des
nouvelles élections s'il va pouvoir le
faire et surtout sivade de nouveaux
contrats par les députés cette fois ci
est ce qu'ils vont lui interdire le no
deal
autrement dit la possibilité de sortir
de l'union européenne sans chercher ou
passer un accord avec les 27 comme le
suggère un jeremy corbyn tout heureux
d'avoir mis hier son échec sur son
adversaire en échec a work in the night
fights willem est né parle 28 des morts
que c'est prescrit
je les ai aucune cents
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors le premier ministre nie pour
l'instant de vol les choses un petit peu
différemment et il l'avait dit juste
avant son opposant travailliste michael
d
[Applaudissements]
alors eh bah baadiko alors cynthia ski
interdire le no deal c'est une bonne
idée surtout on en a marre de cette
histoire longtemps
non mais ça continue ça continue on est
quand même très agacé de ça il ya quand
même un certain nombre de risques et
pour les anglais et pour l'union
européenne on dit a plusieurs
conséquences qui sont possibles menaces
sur l'emploi 180 mille emplois qui sont
menacés en europe 50 mille en france
donc oui évidemment qu'il va falloir
trouver un accord parce que c'est bien
beau de vouloir divorcer m'enfin faut se
mettre d'accord il faut avancer sur
quelque chose de concret
sa personnalité elle nous agace tout
cela jordan shoes est agacé par la
personnalité de ben johnson et par
d'abord une remarque jeremy corbyn a
raison c'est une démocratie
parlementaire
ils ont un parlement où le parlement
peut s'opposer au gouvernement en place
des membres but de ceux qui sont au
pouvoir de la force au pouvoir peuvent
parce qu'ils pensent que c'est l'intérêt
du peuple changer d'avis on a une vraie
démocratie parlementaire
comparativement la france nous allons
monarchie l'assemblée nationale ne sert
absolument à rien c'est une chambre
d'enregistrement où il n'y a pas cette
vivacité d'ailleurs j'ai écouté le débat
hier soir c'est extrêmement intéressant
quand on faisait que regarder la somme
national c'est à mourir maintenant un
autre remarque d'ordre général quand il
ya un référendum donc on demande l'avis
du peuple maintenant démocratie dans
toute l'europe de la grèce en passant
par ailleurs hollande l'irlande la
france ou la grande-bretagne les gens
vont rentrer votre contre cette union
européenne là les dernières élections
européennes en grande bretagne montrent
que apparemment seul et libre etc sitter
ont gagné des points on va se retrouver
dans quelle situation où le peuple vote
pour une sortie l'union européenne et où
le parlement bloc c'est à chaque fois
qu'il ya un deal puisque theresa may a
fait 3000 quand même trois fois rejetée
par ces mêmes parlementaires qui eux
jouent enfin je pense qu'une partie des
parlementaires de ce qu'ils fassent ce
qu'ils sont de rumine ceux qui veulent
rester dans européenne joue le joue ce
jeu blizzard qui a commence à agacer
tout le monde sait ça fait quand même ça
a été voté à 3 ans grec cité deux ans de
débats et là certains alors je comprends
c'est la vie parlementaire certains
disent maintenant jusqu'au 31 va réussir
à faire un accord avec les avec l'union
européenne
c'est pas crédible donc à un moment
donné est ce que on est dans en occident
hélas intéressant par rapport au débat
qui a eu sur la chine et sur la chine
alors sur hong kong
est-ce qu'on est en europe capable de
respecter les volontés du peuple
ou alors on va faire systématiquement
qu'on a fait en 2015 avec la grèce quand
le peuple vote ce qu'il ne veut pas et
ben on fait le contraire quand on en
2005 en france
là on a un parlement qui s'est réunie
pour en 2008 pour aller contre les
volontés du peuple et d'ailleurs
personne ne s'est plaint à l'époque où
john major
avait forcé la main du parlement et en
particulier des consommateurs pour que
le le traité de maastricht soit
appliquée aucun conflit entre une élite
qui pense que la meilleure gouvernance
et une gouvernance européenne de
bruxelles néolibérale et puis d'autres
qui pensent qu'il souveraineté qu'elle
émane du peuple grâce qui va en sortir
sauf que justement là vous présenter les
choses de façon dichotomique mais cette
dichotomie on la voit pas parce que
l'angleterre ce qui se passe c'est que
c'est très compliqué c'est pas en est
pour ou on est content qu'il n'y a pas
deux camps bracke sitters et reminders
ceux qui veulent sortir de l'union et
ceux qui veulent rester il y en a trois
il ya ceux qui veulent sortir il ya ceux
qui veulent rester et à ceux qui veulent
sortir avec un accord et aucun de ces
trois camps n'a la capacité d'imposer sa
volonté aux deux autres et c'est ce qui
se passe donc en résumé ce que disent
les internautes d'ailleurs il dispose
anodine mais pour ceux qui sont
justement côté de corps been mais ne
propose aucune alternative à
l'immobilisme
moi mon avis c'est une crise politique
intérieure majeur et plus précisément à
l'intérieur du parti des conservateurs
parce que c'est quand même parti de là
un premier conservateur à procéder un
référendum en étant sûr de le gagner
david cameron en 2013 il la paix 2009 à
décembre 2016
au mois de juin 2016 il l'a perdu il l'a
perdue et à partir de là le parti
conservateur n'a cessé de ceux de
s'entre déchirer et on en est toujours
là dessus
moi je suis profondément anti brac
sitter contre le break site
mais honnêtement je comprends la
stratégie de boris johnson parce qu'il
faut en sortir et en disant no deal on y
va et puis au moins on a terminé il a au
moins une option alors de toute évidence
si ça passe pas on va vers des élections
générales et au moins ça aura une vertu
soit les conservateurs se font balayer
et on pourra enfin parler du bric site
de façon positive soit les conservateurs
sont confirmées et a souvent
on ira vers 1 m'excite clair et net il
n'y aura plus d'opposition parlementaire
je pense que johnson qui est un
personnage extrêmement facétieux en
moins une vertu c'est celle de proposer
la clarté je pense que les histoires de
principe c'est le parlement qui est
violée par le fait qu'ils soient
suspendus pendant cinq semaines
moi je crois pas du tout puisque ce
parlement là a bloqué trois fois le deal
conclu entre theresa may et bruxelles
c'est un parlement d'obstruction et si
la dissolution n'a pas de sens quand il
ya une obstruction alors il faut
renoncer à la dissolution le problème et
jean fini avec ça c'est que monsieur
johnson pour arriver à dissoudre
il faut qu'il ait les deux tiers de la
chasse est horrible et à mon avis c'est
pas gagné arnaud bonhomme et si vous
regardez ça comment c'est sérieux ou
c'est la crise politique majeure depuis
1940 que connaissent aujourd'hui les
britanniques et alors c'est vrai que
c'est une des figures aussi multiple de
la crise des systèmes de représentation
en europe parce que ce que vous avez
rappelé tout à fait juste vous avez
aujourd'hui des peuples qui votent
systématiquement non chaque fois qu'on
leur pose la question et qui in fine et
voient leur vote infirmée par des élites
politiques ou des élites technocratiques
qui viennent leur expliquer que
finalement ils ont mal voté
donc ça dit quelque chose aussi sur
l'état de fonctionnement des démocraties
occidentales notamment par rapport à
l'enjeu européen mais si on va aux
élections si on va aux élections ce ce
qui est quand même une hypothèse qui ne
faut pas totalement exclure c'est que on
va vraiment voir si ce thé à une
balkanisation accrue du paysage poétique
et annick parce que finalement on voit
bien que le labour a perdu globalement
le vote des classes ouvrières
donc il ne sortira pas il ne sortira
certainement pas vainqueur de cette
élection on voit aujourd'hui la façon
dont les conservateurs aujourd'hui ont
du mal ni filet à offrir une offre
politique homogène et crédible de que ça
va se jouer entre les conservateurs et
le labour et puis il va falloir compter
avec
brixi deux parties et également avec les
libéraux démocrates dont l'équipe qui
survit moment en se radicalisant fera un
score très fort tout à fait donc qu'est
ce qui va ressortir de tout cela c'est
aujourd'hui une véritable énigme
politique est ce qui est quand même
étonnant c'est que la plus vieille
démocratie parlementaire du monde
aujourd'hui est traversée par une crise
qui est une crise majeure
moi je trouve amusant que enfin
intéressant sur le plan de la science
politique que le premier ministre
suspende le parlement depuis que dans un
deuxième temps il propose à tous les
e-menaces tous les députés de leur faire
perdre leur job via des élections
anticipées
donc quelque part et il y à une remise
en cause
c'est non seulement la crise politique
la plus grave depuis 1050 mhz et non
remise en cause depuis le 17e siècle des
fondements de la démocratie
parlementaire
inventé par l'angleterre à l'époque ça
s'appelle comme ça et qui a rayonné dans
le monde entier
donc c'est une crise démocratique dont
on aurait tort de se gausser parce
qu'elle concerne à mon avis quelques par
toutes les démocraties c'est le modèle
même des démocraties
l'angleterre qui est malade aujourd'hui
et il faut quelque part que à mon avis
bruxelles fasse quelque chose
aussi si jamais il faut laisser les
anglais finir régler leurs problèmes
parlementaire entre eux régler le sort
de boris johnson ou boris johnson régler
le sort des parlementaires puis après il
va falloir qu'on s'interroge il faudrait
qu'ils acceptent les conséquences de
leur incapacité à se mettre d'accord
nous disent itx je sens que vous
précisiez ce que
ce que ça veut dire pour vous quelles
seraient les conséquences de cette
incapacité à se mettre d'accord les
députés de l'opposition en grande
bretagne donc interdire un new deal et
non pas un new deal
ont-ils raison c'est la question qu'on
vous pose sur twitter est pour l'instant
vous êtes plutôt du côté est bien de
cette opposition britannique puisque 57%
vous disque que les députés ont raison
de vouloir interdire à nos deals donc
bon christian vous a pas convaincu les
intervenants mais je suis là pour repos
pour prier pour tenter de le faire eux
aussi s'y est dit est ce que bruxelles
joue un rôle colossaux cette couleur si
un deal c'est un grave problème pour
bruxelles et se posera bruxelles fait de
tout ce qui tout ce que tout ce qu'ils
peuvent pour empêcher qu'il ya un deal
ceci a un deal derrière les hongrois
vont demander la même chose il vu les
tensions au sein d'une europe n ai vu
les droits sur les souverainetés
nationales que s'arrogent bruxelles
beaucoup seraient tentés de revenir à
inventer et ce pourquoi avaient voté des
britanniques en fait quand ils ont
intégré les européennes c'est le traité
de rome
mais point n'est pas pas que la justice
la défense la géopolitique le budget des
bandes de jeunes c'est qu'ils d'avoir
surtout pour une démocratie surtout pour
cette démocratie là britannique qui est
très malade et redéploie hier justement
sur ce plateau en évoquer même le risque
d'un éclatement
du royaume uni c'est un scénario extrême
trop pessimiste ou c'est un an c'est un
scénario très réaliste puisqu'on sait
très bien que l'ecosse
d'ailleurs vous certain nombre de
parlementaires ont déposé un recours
contre la décision de suspension du
parlement recours judiciaires devant la
haute cour de décosse mais on sait très
bien que l'ecosse est plus europhiles
que l'angleterre et qu'elle souhaite
garder un lien avec l'union européenne
et garder son appartenance pleine et
entière à l'union européenne
le deuxième problème si l'irlande est
aujourd'hui le paradoxe veut que ce pays
qui était je parle de l'irlande plus
pauvre que lors de terre qui fut pendant
longtemps maltraités par l'angleterre
qui fut une véritable colonie de
l'angleterre est aujourd'hui le pays
prospère qui dicte ses conditions en
refusant le bac stock et qui passe par
bruxelles pour avoir tout le pouvoir
autrement dit l'angleterre est à la
merci un petit peu de l'irlande est sous
la menace de l'ecosse à mon avis les
breaks sitters ne sont pas des patriotes
ils ont mis en danger la nation
britannique
c'est souvent 10 pour les cosses mais il
n'ya pas que être dans l'union
européenne est nulle part si les six
jamais eu un break sic et que des
écossais en particulier pendant dix ans
profite pour demander l'indépendance de
l'école ce qui serait intéressant pour
nous les français si on revient jusqu'à
marie stuart
on réalisera nos objectifs politiques
sur plusieurs siècles mais les anglais
les autres pourraient faire peser le
fait que vous voulez quitter le
commonwealth vous voulez quitter tous
les accords internationaux qu'à signer
en angleterre
il pesait sa pesé dans la balance
je suis pas certain que vous êtes sûr
que vous voulez perdre l'avantagé
stratégique d'être avec les états unis
je suis pas sûr que à la fin les
écossais signe juste pour être sous les
fourches caudines de bruxelles qui
comptent aux qui contrôlerait lors leur
leur budget raison et je crois que si
j'ai dû le principal but britannique je
prendrais pas le risque parce que en
écosse et jeu
je prends juste mais justement il le
prend là il le prend il prend le risque
de l'éclatement et prend le risque du
blocage parlementaire il prend le risque
de la liquidation du parti conservateur
il prend le risque de l'atomisation du
paysage politique britannique
c'est ce qui fait que boris johnson
reste quelque part extrêmement
britannique
dans tous les cas c'est le charme de
l'émission point de vue christian
makarian qui ont à défendre hull de
boris johnson je m'y attendais pas
attardé de façon vous avez bien compris
je vois pas par agora je rends hommage à
vos qualités des stades christian je
pars je n'ai pas dit que c'était votre
votre point de vue